what makes a story boring what makes a
story boring yeah anything with
superheroes yeah sorry
I I don't like superhero movies why I
mean it yeah I've watched i sat down and
watched like a dozen of them once yeah
because I said okay way to look at these
I'm not giving a fair shot I just you
know there's a guy running around in
tights if you're running around in
tights you should either be sword
fighting you know in the 16th century or
in a ballet ballet is great but the I
just I just never buy into it but I you
know is there fun I get people like them
but I I figured out why they're popular
even though I'm not the audience it's
because it's replacing religion the
single largest religious demographic in
the United States under the age of 30
are the non-religious and so religion is
having less importance in life in
America today and I think it's being
replaced with the mythology of the
superheroes because you get to see you
know like the ancient Roman gods the
ancient Greek gods they had old Pantheon
opens it and now that's taken the place
you know
and company and you can dress up like
them and you can go to comic-con and you
can engage in your religion all right
that's my theory that's my crazy writer
theory so then a non superhero movie
what makes a non one boring take that
out of the equation what makes a movie
boring
Oh a story in general I know you talked
early about not enough conflict or
passive characters I think a story is
boring if it doesn't matter if there are
no stakes if the people in the movie if
they don't care a lot about what is
happening and what they're doing then
the audience won't care that's to me
what makes us so important at Eric Terr
and they need to Rea they need $10,000
why do they need 10,000
are they paying for their child's
operation to save their life that's
important I'd be like oh that matters
okay are they just trying to buy a car
so they can go to work or like okay
that's a real thing I guess but so what
you know oh you know James Bond is is
you know it's he does he have to kill
this guy because you know because the
guy took his parking space or is he
doing it to save the world you know why
you know unless you the French the
French can make movies about being
boring to make those work you know
there's certain indie films where you
can you can actually delve into that in
a deeper way but for me that's it if the
stakes aren't there if it if the story
if the hero succeeds or doesn't succeed
or whatever why does it matter it
doesn't matter I don't care so for you
when you go to see a film and I know you
said lately that you've been so busy
with all this you don't even have time
to watch television but before all that
could you tell within the first few
minutes I was going to be boring oh
absolutely absolutely my girlfriend
bless her heart just has to listen to me
you know after the first minutes of
immunity I'll say this is what this
movie is about just because I can't
can't help it but like we recently saw
their finest you know their finest is a
British film about a woman who is hired
to make propaganda films in World War
two in England and in the first few
minutes of that movie they bring you to
London world war two under the Blitz
you know there's bombs coming down and
there's this young woman who needs a job
and because her husband is having a hard
time getting hired and so she needs a
job and she goes into the office of the
propaganda that the propaganda film
office with the British government they
they call her in and the stakes are
there for two reasons if she doesn't get
a job okay her and her husband or she in
her husband
and if she doesn't make good propaganda
films then the public you know that is
being bombed okay may feel more bleak
whereas if she does a good job with
these films they'll feel better no we
all know how World War two ends so
that's it's not like if that's and down
we're wondering Gigi who wins here you
know but it's super but we don't know
how individual people felt in London at
the time being bombed so that's a
mystery we're gonna find that out so
immediately the first five six minutes
of the film you care if she gets this
job and if she's good at it what was it
about those stakes because I mean the
storyline sounds great but if someone
else did it and the stakes weren't there
there must have been little nuances
about how they drew you in that that
made you sit up on the edge of your seat
a little more well they had several
kinds of stakes they had just personal
the war they had the big stakes the the
broad stakes the morale of London the
morale of England during this fight
those were the big stakes then they had
the personal stakes she was a woman they
brought her in it was this this film
office was run all by all men okay and
they were very dismissive of her they
had been told by a higher-up that the
propaganda films that they were making
that the female dialogue was terrible
and so they said you know well let's
bring in this girl and she'll write the
female bits and they bring her in
they're very dismissive you know you do
all the rest of the work my dear you
just just fill in the female bits oh
yeah it was very dismissive so right
away there's this chauvinism appropriate
for the time and and you're like hey
that's not right you know 2017 you're
like yeah you know so there's these
immediate personal stakes as well so
they added a layer to it that that was
treading throughout the movie but it
wasn't all about just girl power they
moved beyond that later in the movie
deeper sure but that that those
different layers it sounds like drew you
in there were the higher stakes than her
her stakes at home and then you add this
sort of like combative environment that
she has to go into so there was many
things interesting right ok so then when
you see a movie that within the first
five minutes it falls flat are we only
seeing one layer is that sometimes why
orgy it sounds like we really can't
break it down to a science but yeah it's
not a sign if it was a science then you
know we have computers do it we just uh
nobody knows what's gonna be hit one
isn't and there's so many factors in
making a movie so many factors from the
script to what the director is doing
with and the cast you know oh one a cast
member one actor may make a character
sympathetic the other another different
actor might make them annoying you know
it's just so so many factors by the way
I like the name of your website film
courage I'm curious how you came up with
that because it takes courage to make a
movie even if you make a bad movie I
mean nobody says something a bad way if
you make a bad movie it still takes
courage I'm not talking about the fake
kind of courage that like Apple has when
they take away our headphone jack on the
iPhone but it does take courage and to
make a good movie takes even more
courage you have to take a chance you
have to go out on a limb you have to do
something that hasn't been tried before
because if we've seen it all before
why do we want to see it again why why
does it take courage because it seems
like if it's in you and it just pours
out wouldn't wouldn't nothing stop you
or is it putting it out in the public
space and holding it up to the light for
scrutiny that's where the courage comes
in too well that definitely but to do it
in the first place I mean to go into
show business in the first place on the
face of it it's a stupid idea
300 people moved to Los Angeles every
day to become actors okay that is a
million people over ten years
who've come here just to be actors now
the odds if you just look at the numbers
the odds of you becoming successful as
an actor are terrible as a writer
they're terrible yeah so if you look at
it logically you go well am I gonna do
that I'm gonna become a doctor I do
something else because it's this there's
a there's a very clear path I get my
degree I go to medical school I become a
doctor it's clear it's logical it's
reasonable so to even go into show
business takes courage because the odds
are you're going to fail so the people
who make it are the ones who can't do
anything else and by that I mean they
won't get out of bed for anything else
they just can't they have to do it
they're driven to do it those are the
ones who don't give up who keep going
because they can't do anything else they
just keep doing it
you